l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
[Musique]
julian assange fête aujourd'hui ses 50
ans derrière les barreaux le journaliste
est est toujours incarcéré dans une
prison de haute sécurité à londres
toute la semaine ses soutiens se sont
mobilisés ils continuent de dénoncer une
détention arbitraire et politique
l'auvergnat delta se propage à vitesse
grand v sur le continent africain où
grande à sambi république démocratique
du congo les systèmes de santé déjà
fragile font face à un afflux de
patients qu'ovide certains états optent
pour le confinement
tour d'horizon dans ce journal
[Musique]
la france relance sa coopération avec
l'armée malienne
ils avaient suspendu dans la foulée dans
ce bon coup d'état c'était en mai dans
un communiqué paris déclare prendre avec
des engagements des autorités maliennes
de transition des opérations militaires
conjointes ainsi que des missions
nationales de conseils rome
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france c'est en prison
que julian assange célèbre ses 50 ans le
lanceur d'alerté toujours incarcéré à
londres les états unis qui demandent son
extradition lui reproche des faits
d'espionnage ses soutiens dénoncent eux
une détention politique
toute la semaine ils se sont donc
mobilisés un peu partout dans le monde
monaco dès lors c'est l'histoire d'un
journaliste en prison dont les
révélations ont changé le cours des
choses à jamais cette année julian
assange fondateur de wikileaks passera
son 50e anniversaire
derrière les barreaux de la prison de
belmarsh à l'est de londres
ces soutiens continue de se mobiliser
pour faire valoir la liberté d'informer
et protester contre une détention jugées
arbitraires et politique pour
sensibiliser le public ils ont lancé la
assange week sur twitter à stella
maurice la compagne du lanceur dallaire
devenu aujourd'hui l'un de ses relais
médiatiques encourage ses abonnés à
organiser des événements symboliques les
événements locaux sont encouragés vous
n'avez pas besoin d'autorisation aucun
événement n'est trop petit le but faire
prendre conscience que julian est un
prisonnier d'opinion et célébrer son
travail jeunes et gabriel shipton
respectivement père et frère du
journaliste sont actuellement en tournée
aux états unis pour alerter également
sur la situation de julian assange
et si certains n'ont pas pu faire le
déplacement c'est le geste qui compte
le 28 juin reporters sans frontières a
lancé le hashtag à pebble d'assange
largement relayé sur les réseaux sociaux
alors que l'anniversaire de julian
assange approche je rejoins l'appel free
assange
les charges contre lui devrait être
abandonné et ils devraient être
immédiatement relâchés fait ce que ce
soit son dernier anniversaire derrière
les barreaux le député travailliste
richard burden a adressé une lettre au
ministère de la justice au sujet d'un
refus d' entretien vidéo avec julian
assange cher gouverneur nous sommes
profondément préoccupés par votre refus
persistant ainsi que du ministère de la
justice d'autoriser une réunion vidéo en
ligne entre julian assange et un groupe
multi partite de parlementaires
britanniques
cette affaire a des implications
importantes pour la liberté de la presse
vous avez le pouvoir d'accorder une
telle réunion et nous
man dont de faciliter une réunion en
ligne sans plus tarder la procédure
d'extradition de julian assange devrait
reprendre cet automne dans une interview
accordée au journal l'humanité
c'est là maurice accompagne dit être
inquiète à propos de son état de santé
depuis son arrestation en 2019
il a eu de véritable période de crise
physique et mentale du fait de la
détention et de son quotidien
julian est en détention depuis deux ans
et demi désormais ses conditions de
détention reste désastreuse en étant
incarcéré dans la prison la plus célèbre
du royaume uni aux côtés des pires
criminels du pays de prisonniers
condamnés pour assassinat de barons de
la drogue
le 4 janvier londres refuse son
extradition vers les etats-unis
l'administration byden fait appel
finalement le président démocrate suit
les pas de donald trump l'administration
by donne doit avoir le courage désormais
de mettre un terme à cette saga si le
président des états unis tient
véritablement à la liberté de la presse
et entend protéger le premier amendement
joe biden et son administration ne cesse
de communiquer sur la liberté de la
presse et veulent apparaître sur la
scène internationale comme son plus
fervent défenseur
la détention de julian assange démontre
clairement leur hypocrisie et celle des
occidentaux si julian assange est
extradé vers les états unis il risque
jusqu'à 175 en prison pour avoir diffusé
plus de 700 mille documents
confidentiels sur les activités
militaires et diplomatiques américaine
révélant et des crimes de guerre et
crimes contre l'humanité notamment en
irak et en afghanistan des informations
et qui ont mis à nu les guerres
américaines et qui ont été reprises par
les médias du monde entier et pour
stéphanie gibeau hauteur de la traque
des lanceurs d'alerté préfacé par julian
assange le monde occidental peine à se
mobiliser pour sa défense souvenez-vous
de du président macron et de madame
angela merkel qui sont immédiatement
précipités médiatiquement sur la sphère
navale nick secoué
les médias il ya quelques mois et dans
la mesure où les comment dire les les
ressortissants sont deux pays que nos
démocraties occidentales considèrent
être soit des dictatures soit des pays
en développement il ya immédiatement
immédiatement une prise de parole sur
justement les droits de l'homme et le
respect des droits de l'homme
or pour assange qui est donc enfermé à
londres depuis je crois que c'est la
dixième année 1,6 en six ans et demi à
l'ambassade de l'équateur plus deux ans
et demi non dans cette prison de belles
marges vous savez plus de neuf années
que ça dure
il n'y a personne et là c'est absolument
choquant parce que justement on voit
qu'il ya deux poids deux mesures
l'occident a beaucoup de mal à dire
qu'elle a des prisonniers politiques et
des prisonniers d'opinion et en france à
paris ils étaient une dizaine à se
rassembler square marie niche dans le 8e
arrondissement autour d'un pique nique
pour réclamer la libération de julian
assange et put effet participants
ça fait deux ans que je lutte pour la
libération de julian assange qui est et
c'est pas mon avis c'est une opinion
largement partagée
la ferme de presse la plus importante du
siècle mois et camarades ici on n'a pas
l'intention de ne pas marquer le coup
pour julian assange lui dire qu'il n'est
pas seul ça on le sait est en tout cas
qu'on l'abondant a pas la lutte jusqu'à
ce qu'il soit libre ça c'est clair parce
qu'il ya quand même une idée avec ses
cet anniversaire de dire quand même aux
gens que
c'est pas un combat perdu d'abord que il
ya encore il dépend de la mobilisation
de l'opinion et donc ça c'est quand même
quelque chose il faut pas oublier je
défend la cause d'assange depuis très
longtemps bien avant qu'ils ne soient
enlevés de l'ambassade et est incarcéré
parce que c'est une cause qui me semble
élémentaire pour toute personne
soucieuse de la liberté d'informer
liberté d'expression la liberté et le
droit même de dénoncer des crimes et des
les agissements de l' empire américain
donc c'est une cause qui me semble
évidente je constate que malheureusement
c'est pas le cas pour toutes les forces
politiques associatives syndicales
je le déplore mais bon il n'est jamais
trop tard pour pour rejoindre le combat
il n'épargnait aucun continent le
variant delta suscite l'inquiétude il
est à l'origine d'une flambée de
l'épidémie en indonésie en moins d'un
mois
le pays a vu son nombre de cas
quotidiens plus que quadruplé avec un
nouveau record de près de 28000
nouvelles contaminations enregistré ce
samedi le point sur la situation avec un
maya souple et un million de doses
injectées quotidiennement en juillet et
2 millions à partir du mois d'août
c'est l'objectif fixé par les autorités
indonésiennes
face à la recrudescence des cas de kovy
19 les déplacements pendant les vacances
de l'aïd en mai dernier et la
propagation du ver ion delta force le
gouvernement à prendre de nouvelles
restrictions d'urgence signé comme nous
le savons la pandémie de kobe 19 s'est
développée très rapidement ces derniers
jours en raison de nouveaux variants qui
constitue également un problème grave
dans de nombreux pays
cette situation nous oblige à prendre
des mesures plus décisives afin
qu'ensemble nous puissions endiguer la
propagation du comice 19 télétravail
fermeture des lieux de culte et centres
commerciaux vente uniquement à emporter
ce samedi les indonésiens connaissent
les plus durs restrictions de l'année la
dégradation du contexte sanitaire
met à mal la situation dans les hôpitaux
surchargés et contraints de refuser
certains patients les habitants de
l'archipel doivent trouver eux mêmes
leurs provisions d'oxygène et parfois
attendre plusieurs jours avant d'être
prise en charge
l'hôpital m'a dit qu'il ne pouvait pas
me fournir d'oxygène et que je devais
trouver mon propre oxygène pour mon mari
j'ai deux tubes d'oxygène le premier que
j'ai mis à l'hôpital pour mon mari est
le deuxième que je remplis ici pour la
sauvegarde pour pallier au manque de
lits des tentes ont été montées aux
abords des hôpitaux et permettent aux
malades de recevoir leurs premiers soins
non loin de là les fosses communes sont
creusés pour être aussitôt utiliser si
l'archipel composé de milliers d'îles
rend complexe la campagne de vaccination
le président souhaite doubler le taux
quotidien de vacciner d'ici le mois
d'août ce jeudi dans le cadre de
l'accélération de la campagne des
milliers d'indonésiens attendaient leurs
doses devant un stade de la banlieue de
jakarta abk6 sur 270 millions
d'indonésiens seulement 5% de la
population a été vaccinée à ce jour et
on part maintenant en iran foulard
menace plane d'une cinquième vague avec
l'arrivée de ce variant delta la
campagne de vaccination tourne au
ralenti en raison d'un manque de doses
le point avec faits réels benavides
bullion près de quatorze mille nouveaux
cas recensés ce vendredi en iran des
chiffres qui rappelle les vagues
épidémiques de l'an dernier qui avait
fait de ce pays le plus touché par la
crise du coc vide 19 au moyen-orient ce
samedi le président sortant met en garde
contre la souche indienne du virus ces
dernières semaines il a été annoncé que
le variant telle taille est entrée dans
le pays par le sud et le sud est
il faut donc veiller à ne pas le
propager dans le pays
[Musique]
nous craignons d'être sur la voie d'une
cinquième vague dans tout le pays
le variant delta est déjà actif dans
quatre provinces
le sistan balouchistan kerremans ormeaux
ce gant et farce c'est aussi le cas dans
la province de téhéran où dix villes
dans la capitale sont classées rouge
soit le niveau de risque épidémiologique
le plus élevé selon le code couleur
adoptée par les autorités pour vaincre
cette mutation indienne et éviter
d'aggraver un bilan humain très lourd
depuis 2020 avec 84 mille morts dus
qu'aux vide
le gouvernement souhaite vacciner
davantage pour cela six vaccins locaux
sont à l'étude
un moyen pour téhéran de contrer les
sanctions économiques américaines qui
lui empêche d'importer un nombre
suffisant de doses pour vacciner sa
population
mais pour le moment aucune mise sur le
marché n'a été autorisé par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
soutenu par les pays amis avec le
spoutnik russe le sinopharm chinois ou
le coc vaccine indien ou encore des
doses d'astrazeneca dans le cadre du
programme international kovacs la
république islamique reste optimiste et
espère avoir vacciné les personnes
vulnérables et âgées de plus de 60 ans
avant la fin du mois d'août
en afrique les autorités et peine à
contenir la propagation du variant delta
focus sur le libéria et l'ouganda des
pays déjà en grande difficulté avant le
vide la crise sanitaire met désormais en
péril des millions de vies sébastien
abba
des abris de fortune pratiquement à même
le sol et des moustiquaires
c'est le quotidien des quelques 600
vendeurs entassés dans le plus grand
marché de kampala la capitale ougandaise
à bourg qui comme eco vendeur de légumes
s'en accommode comico je dors sur un
matelas et quelques bouts de carton avec
ma moustiquaire c'est tout au marché qui
est un espace ouvert bien sûr qu'on sent
le froid autour de nous ce n'est pas
comme à la maison où je peux fermer la
porte face à une flambée record des
nouveaux cas de coronavirus le
gouvernement a mis en place un
confinement très strictes de 42 jours
les trois quarts des commerçants du
marché de naka ce héros sont rentrés
chez eux ceux qui restent ont été
autorisés à continuer leur activité à
condition d'y rester jour et nuit
la vie a changé parce que je ne suis pas
à la maison tout est plus difficile se
laver vous savez pour les femmes c'est
assez compliqué laver ses affaires
la façon dont on dort les choses ne sont
pas faciles
[Applaudissements]
au liberia ce sont les hôpitaux sont
submergés cinq nouveaux cas ont déjà été
dépistés dans l'hôpital d'un bidonville
de monrovia ce n'était pas facile
c'était presque comme si j'avais
renoncer à ma respiration
parce que ça a commencé à la maison
quand ça a commencé j'étais seul j'étais
allongé
j'ai voulu me moucher et ça a pris une
autre tournure
alors pour éviter d'être en rupture
l'établissement hospitalier n'a pas eu
d'autre choix que de produire son propre
oxygène dans des périodes comme celle-ci
une bouteille d'oxygène est vendu à 35
dollars donc lorsque vous avez des
patients qui ont besoin d'oxygène
les patients susceptibles d'avoir besoin
d'oxygène il n'est pas facile de se
procurer une bouteille pour 35 $ par les
temps qui courent cette unité de
production d'oxygène et donc une
bénédiction
si le liberia fait face à une troisième
vague inquiétante
l'afrique reste pour l'instant nous
continent le moins touché par le cours
aux navires us en tunisie à la crise
sanitaire s'ajoute une crise économique
et politique le dialogue national est
mise à mal
de quoi fragiliser le chef du
gouvernement michel mais chichi
reportage est unie st de bassam chebbi
et des ananas frais dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée des représentants du peuple
les députés se font de plus en plus
rares avec un taux d'absentéisme
dépassant les 22 % que l'on soit de la
majorité ou de l'opposition
nombreux sont ceux qui semblent avoir
baissé les bras à l'heure où la tunisie
traverse la pire crise de son histoire
tension sociale inédite blocage
politique sans précédent et profonde
économique dans le pays tous les
indicateurs sont au rouge alors que
plusieurs partis organisations mettent
en garde contre l'explosion de la
situation sociale dans le pays
que l'on soit de droite ou de gauche
nous allâmes nationale semble apparaître
comme le dernier recours pour sortir de
la crise il faut absolument que le
dialogue soit renoué entre les trois
chefs
car dans le cas contraire c'est une
guerre civile qui nous attend notre
condition et le respect aujourd'hui il
ya des députés qui insultent ouvertement
dans l'hémicycle le président de la
république
quand vous voulez vous après que le chef
de l'état les reçoivent on demande que
ces derniers présentant ses excuses
ennahda a toujours été pour le dialogue
national notre parti a toujours demandé
à la classe politique de dialoguer à
commencer par le chef de l'état et le
chef du gouvernement pour préparer le
dialogue national un dialogue sans veto
ni aucune condition et wallis et futuna
oui c'est chaud le dialogue national ne
doit être une copie conforme de celui de
2013 il doit être un dialogue en vue du
partage des pouvoirs
cela doit être un dialogue structuré et
efficace pour en sortir des solutions
économiques et sociales notre parti a
émis deux conditions à commencer par la
démission du gouvernement mais chichi
qui à nos yeux cristallise tous les
problèmes que rencontre notre pays et
deuxième condition le dialogue doit se
passer sous la tutelle du président de
la république au coeur de cette crise
politique
un des accords existants entre le
président de la république ait sayed et
le chef du gouvernement michel mais
chichi en raison du remaniement
ministériel du 16 janvier dernier malgré
l'approbation du parlement
le président ça aide a refusé de
convoquer les nouveaux ministres pour la
prestation de serment constitutionnel au
palais de carthage
estimant qu'elle amendement était
entachée de violations
trop pour rejeter en bloc par les
chichis de son côté le puissant syndicat
de l'union générale tunisienne du
travail est monté au créneau accusant
kaïs saïed de proposer sa propre feuille
de route est de court-circuiter le
dialogue national une initiative du
syndicat appuyé par une majorité de la
classe politique tunisienne unft
raillère iddri cette crise est le
résultat d'un dysfonctionnement interne
de l'appareil politique tunisien
rythmé par des conflits d'intérêts
partisans entre les différents pouvoirs
les différents partis mais aussi
l'ingérence de plusieurs puissances
étrangères
le dialogue national peut être une
solution à beaucoup de problèmes
premièrement il faut revoir le système
électoral deuxièmement il doit y avoir
une reprise du dialogue entre le chef de
l'état
le chef du gouvernement et le président
du parlement chacun doit connaître son
rôle à la question ce dialogue vous
présenter la solution finale à cette
sortie de crise il est difficile de
répondre par l'affirmative car ce qui
les oppose et bien supérieurs à ceux qui
les lie et chacun d'entre eux à sa
propre feuille de route
il en va de même pour leurs relations
avec les pays étrangers
ce qui ne fait qu'accentuer la crise on
pense notamment aux nombreux
déplacements de monsieur ghannouchi à
ankara pour rencontrer le président r
douanes ou encore ceux avec fayez elle
sa rage le chef du gouvernement d'union
national libyen
absence de leadership gouvernance bloqué
surendettement et chris partisane sc
l'état dans lequel se trouve aujourd'hui
la tunisie dans cette situation des plus
incertaines nombreux sont ceux qui
voient en ce possible dialogue national
la solution miracle alors que dans le
pays les manifestations populaires
s'accentue pour demander une refonte
totale du système politique en place
la france reprend sa coopération
bilatérale avec l'armée malienne elle y
avait mis en termes il ya un mois après
un nouveau putsch
plus de 5000 militaires français sont
aujourd'hui déployés au sahel mais le
président macron récemment annoncé un
prochain des engagements de la france il
se fera progressivement la force et un
bar kahn devrait disparaître au profit
d'un dispositif focaliser sur la lutte
antiterroriste et l'accompagnement au
combat des armées locales
en attendant les opérations militaires
conjointes vont reprendre écoutez la
réaction de ce parlementaire membre du
conseil national de transition au manioc
le voilier est unique c'est le val it on
si l'ensemble de la sous-région qui
tombera au la ville les effets et les
ricochets récemment en côte d'ivoire il
terrière mans au niger et au burkina
faso
peut-être demain si le mali continue de
sombrer si le sénégal la mauritanie la
guinée qui risquent de tomber et tous
ces pays là sont des partenaires
stratégiques de la france
si au cinéma lido si cette digue est
rompu cette digue malienne est rompu si
ce sera aussi une partie de l'europe
occidentale qui sera touché on l'a vu de
l'immigration à outrance et le
terrorisme je dirais même plus
aujourd'hui c'est des choses sur
lesquelles la france devrait se poser
comme question avant de prendre un tel
acte j'ai tiré malheureusement nous
avons perdu un mois
contrôler la lune dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme
c'est un mois de perdu
elle a dit m poutine approuve la
stratégie de sécurité nationale de la
russie adopté en 2015 elle doit être
modifié tous les six ans conformément à
la loi la priorité de cette nouvelle
édition et la protection des citoyens
russes prévenir les actes hostiles qui
menace la souveraineté l'intégrité
territoriale du pays
la cybersécurité a également été
désignée comme une nouvelle priorité
nationale stratégique
enfin la question de la compétitivité
pour une croissance économique rapide
décryptage de françois chauve ancien
général de brigade d'experts en
géostratégie
la russie a montré depuis 2015 avec son
intervention notamment en appui la syrie
qu'elle était capable de projeter des
forces qu'elles étaient capables de
mener une guerre lointaine qu'elle était
aussi capable de tirer des missiles à
longue portée
donc je dirais qu indirectement ce que
vous poser comme question et la question
du réarmement d'un certain nombre
d'états aujourd'hui que ce soit la
russie que ce soit les états unis que ce
soit pas de même la france
il y a une certaine incertitude sur
l'avenir du monde aujourd'hui et on voit
bien que les dépenses d'armement chaque
année augmente désormais pas forcément
d'ailleurs dans les états que je viens
de citer
mais globalement ce qui veut dire que
les risques de guerres aujourd'hui sont
loin d'être exclue maintenant entre ces
pays que je viens de citer le risque de
guerre me semble peu probable en
revanche l'intervention militaire dans
d'autres pays me semble beaucoup plus
vraisemblable la russie qui accuse les
occidentaux de vouloir transformer en
espace de coopération en zone de
confrontation moscou est revenu sur les
raisons de tensions en mer noire
dernièrement navire britannique s'est vu
repoussé par des coups de semonce le
lendemain les forces russes escortaient
rang navire néerlandais la
correspondance de vérins goffman la mer
noire et progressivement transformé par
les états unis et leurs alliés de
l'espace de coopération une zone de
confrontation a déclaré la porte parole
de la diplomatie russe marya zakharova
pour elle les exercices militaires
lancés par washington kiev et leurs
alliés le 28 juin ont clairement une
connotation anti russe
un déploiement militaire de cette
ampleur près du territoire russe suscite
une réaction adéquate de notre part la
zone de la mer noire en fait et
progressivement transformé par
washington et ses alliés de l'espace de
coopération qui se construisait là-bas
en une zone de confrontation c'est fait
délibérément dans l'intention de rendre
instable une autre région du monde sous
la direction des etats-unis pour qu'elle
commence à présenter une menace
il ne fait aucun doute que ces
manoeuvres ont une connotation anti
russe évidence de ces maillots vrai il
ya des intérêts si ce qui épate texte ni
rose devra être ni fakir sam ligne les
exercices militaires baptisée sea breeze
impliquant quelques 5000 militaires et
39e se passe sur fond de tensions entre
la russie et la grande-bretagne après
l'intrusion dans les eaux territoriales
russes le 23 juin du destroyer
britannique defender le président russe
vladimir poutine a qualifié l'incident
de provocation tout d'abord c'est bien
sûr une provocation une provocation
évidente même si vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que le monde s'est trouvée au
bord d'une guerre mondiale mais bien sûr
que non même si nous avions couler ce
navire il serait difficile d'imaginer
que le monde était au bord d'une
troisième guerre mondiale puisque ceux
qui le font savent qu'ils ne peuvent pas
sortir vainqueurs de cette guerre
je rappelle que l'ambassade de russie à
washington avait exhorté les états unis
et leurs alliés à ne pas pratiquer
d'opérations militaires en mer noire
soulignant que si manoeuvre on
augmenterait le risque d'incident
involontaire
ils étaient entre 650 et 3000
manifestants a protesté aujourd'hui à
perpignan contre le rassemblement
national le parti de marine le pen
réunis en congrès ce week-end marine le
pen accueillis par le maire est reine de
la ville louis aliot près d'une semaine
après la défaite aux régionales le
numéro deux du parti jordan bachleda a
déclaré que rien n'était perdu chili
encore un chemin vers la victoire à
moins d'un an de la présidentielle
associations syndicats et partis de
gauche organisée en même temps une
contre-manifestation venus de plusieurs
départements de la région les
protestataires ont défilé notamment
derrière une banderole proposant de
lutter ensemble contre l'extrême droite
l'idée c'est de dire que les idées
d'extrême droite sont un danger pour la
population notamment aussi pour les
travailleurs et travailleuses
souhaitons pas la division 1 au
contraire nous voulons l'égalité
nous voulons une société de justice
sociale et nous refusons toutes les
divisions notamment liées à l'origine de
la jeunesse se mobilise au maximum par
l'agenais 60 de la société contre s'ils
dépassent qu'une fois au pouvoir n'aura
plus pour pleurer
que faut pas qu'ils aillent pour savoir
que ma ville sert de tremplin pour ces
idées là ça me ça me révulse
et il faut donc venir exprimer son
opposition mais aussi réfléchir ensemble
aux commandes proposer d'autres choses
que tu valises et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
journal dans une trentaine de minutes à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance vous avez
choisi le jour à bagdad alors je suis
arrivé en 2005 pour étudier